how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and today after quite some time now
we finally have some spider-man 3 news
the last news that we got first
spider-man 3 unfortunately was the fact
that spider-man 3 had been delayed then
we got news that spider-man 3 was going
to start production initially without
Tom Holland because he would be filming
for Uncharted again not really any good
news about spider-man 3 until today
which we're going to break down in this
video but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU and
spider-man 3 and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
black panther Funko pop all you have to
do to enter subscribe to my channel like
this video and leave a comment about the
video down below so great news for
spider-man fans who have been waiting to
hear a lot of good news there is a lot
coming and that is because according to
a new casting grid production for
spider-man 3 is starting in September
that's right a new casting grid says
that the production for spider-man 3 is
going to be starting in September and
this casting grid also lines up with
previous reports that the film is going
to be shooting at locations such as New
York Los Angeles Atlanta and Iceland
very unique locations and not your
typical just filming in Atlanta at
Marvel Studios locations but considering
the fact that spider-man is most likely
going to be on the run in spider-man 3
these makes sense different studios and
different sceneries will allow for much
more diverse shooting but the real great
news about this is that we only have to
wait about three more months for filming
to start which means we're going to be
getting a ton of new information pretty
soon which is great because spider-man 3
is one of the upcoming Marvel films that
we don't really know too much about in
fact up to this day we have nothing that
is really confirmed about the plot for
spider-man 3 there's plenty of leaks and
there's plenty of speculation but we
have nothing confirmed but the biggest
rumor that is going around that
everybody is really excited for is the
fact that daredevil could possibly
appear in spider-man 3 it's been
rumoured that Marvel got the rights back
to daredevil earlier than
expected which was supposed to be at the
end of the year but rumor has it that
Marvel Studios has the rights back
already to daredevil which means when
spider-man starts filming in September
they could use daredevil and daredevil
is a character that actually fits quite
perfectly with what we think the plot is
going to be for spider-man 3 at the end
of spider-man far from home he was
pegged as a murderer and now all of New
York and pretty much the whole entire
world is going to think that spider-man
killed Mysterio and tried to kill a
bunch of other people as well so
needless to say he's going to need some
help one in the legal department and two
probably fighting off all of the bad
guys that are going to be coming for him
and that is what makes Matt Murdock the
perfect candidate to show up to help
Peter Parker he's not only a lawyer but
he's also daredevil a combination that
people have been wanting to see for some
time now spider-man with daredevil and
if the rumor that Marvel Studios got the
rights back to daredevil early are true
that could mean they are planning to use
him in spider-man 3 but again it's just
a rumor for now but there is something
else that is kind of interesting that
points to daredevil appearing in
spider-man 3 there's an Instagram
account by the name of Spidey's number
one fan now this account is ran by the
character flash that exists in the
spider-man universe spider-man
homecoming and spider-man far from home
and this account acts like it exists in
the spider-man universe and this account
did a ask me anything in which the
question was which superheroes have you
met excluding Spidey and this is what he
posted before I met Spidey I met this
one dude with horns and stuff he kind of
saved me from probably getting stabbed
kind of looked like this and as you can
see here it's clearly daredevil now
there's really not much known about this
Instagram account but some say that it
could be owned by Sony and this could be
some weird teasing that they're doing
but of course right now nobody can
confirm that but that doesn't stop us
from wanting daredevil to show up in
spider-man 3 but the good news is that
production for spider-man 3 will be
starting in September in which we will
find out a lot more about the film I'm
sure Tom will be spoiling some stuff for
us plus we'll get leaked photos of the
Senate leaked videos as well plus
usually when production starts for a
film we typically get the title not too
long after so we're going to start
getting a lot of news about spider-man 3
very soon in the future so if you want
to stay up to date on all things
relating to spider-man 3
be sure to subscribe and let me know
what your hopes are for spider-man 3 in
the comments down below
would you like daredevil to show up or
would you like somebody like Jennifer
Walters aka she hoped to show up and
help Peter Parker and who are you hoping
will be the villain let me know
everything that you want from spider-man
3 in the comments down below and don't
forget to like this video and for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof